Ginger armor is the daily moisturizing
mineral sunscreen perfect for any skin
type chemical sunscreens can cause
health issues including skin irritation
and stinging eyes but with ginger armors
ingredients from plants and minerals and
it being scent free and rubbing on
invisibly in seconds it's the best get
15 off with code Pacman using the link
below welcome to 2023 hope everybody had
a good New Year we're going to start
today by talking about the new Heroes of
many young men I'm talking about people
like of course Jordan Peterson but more
recently Andrew Tate this guy who goes
by the name liver King and some of the
other folks in this universe you know
many of you emailed me about Andrew Tate
being arrested in Europe I don't really
have anything to say about his arrest
it's a law enforcement matter I don't
know know if Greta tunberg's tweet was
part of what ultimately got him arrested
because of a pizza box indicating where
he was I don't know about any I don't
have any commentary about any of that
but I do think it's time that I talk a
little bit more
about the Andrew Tates plural right
these figures like Andrew Tate and some
of the right-wing political commentators
are in that group in a particular way
certainly Jordan Peterson you know I'm
including liver King in this and some of
the uh Tick-Tock
workout and supplement type influencers
because what they really are are
scamming people mostly young men and it
is very sad to see and maybe we can talk
about it a little bit and maybe break
somebody out of it or at least get
somebody to reconsider what they've
fallen for so let's explain what's going
on uh these folks Andrew Tate Peterson
liver King Etc
there are just a few examples of people
who have become popular
to make it really simple to simplify why
they've become popular they appeal to
young men
who feel victimized sometimes
underrepresented in mainstream culture
and Society
disadvantaged certainly dissatisfied
with either their level of success their
amount of muscle their physique when it
comes to like the liver Kings their job
success their success with women
do some older men follow these guys yeah
do some women follow these guys sure but
if you go to a Jordan Peterson event or
you see who follows Andrew Tate or liver
King it's mostly men and they're mostly
relatively young now there's nothing
wrong with that in principle that's not
the point I'm making there's all sorts
of different people whose followers are
concentrated among some demographics and
not others that's not the problem that's
the context these types like the Tates
and the Petersons Etc
they offer a message that is of freedom
of Liberty
of men taking control of their lives and
fighting back against a culture or
society that is putting them down
everything about culture and Society is
helping others it's either helping women
or it's helping people who are already
wealthy or whatever right but the thing
about it is that when you look more
closely at the message you find that the
disappointments they address the
Grievances they speak to
these are standard ones in the
prototypical
self-help uh discourse just completely
standard nothing unique about it and and
specifically many of them are actually
tailored to young men I've said before
Jordan Peterson's advice is almost
completely Universal it's been done a
thousand times and that's okay what
Jordan Peterson does is he packages it
in a particular way the personality of
Peterson the demeanor the stuff
surrounding it is somewhat different and
unique to a degree
and so they take those obstacles or
those problems they combine it with
their own delusions of grandeur and
sense of how powerful they themselves
are and also the victimhood framing
we're victims so are you I'll teach you
to overcome this this victimization that
you're suffering from now they're all a
slightly different brand or category
with Jordan Peterson it's more cultural
and societal well I'm going to help you
overcome the social and societal and
cultural issues that are holding you
down with Andrew Tate it's more overtly
about how to get women and make money in
business and then with liver King it's
how to get muscular and live this
ancestral Primal lifestyle which is
completely absurd by the way but not the
subject of this particular video so it's
versions of the exact same thing the
really funny thing or maybe it's the sad
thing or maybe it's the ironic thing is
the Revolutionary self-framing that
these guys do when you listen closely it
almost sounds like Marxist rhetoric
except it's the epitome of grifter
capitalism and I'll explain exactly what
I mean by that when you listen to
Peterson or Tate or or liver King and
these others they sort of talk like they
are the Marxist leaders who are going to
fire everybody up they're gonna red pill
you
and you're finally going to overthrow
your oppressors the capitalist like that
but that's in Marxism except they are
actually the capitalists they've simply
adapted a rhetoric
and it's actually working really really
well liver King it's totally overt the
capitalist grift is overt he's selling
supplements it's unclear liver King even
takes his supplements he previously
claimed to eat insane amounts of raw
animal organs every day some emails that
leaked exposed that liver King doesn't
really eat much of those organs at all
it's all a capitalist grift to sell
supplements okay with Jordan Peterson
it's he sells books and um does personal
appearances you know speaking gigs at
which he gets paid and the language is
more about take control of your life
take control of it don't don't let uh
don't don't let the leftists suppress
you don't let those who want to compel
speech oppress you don't let big Tech
oppress you or whatever the case may be
and with Andrew Tate it's you know he's
got his courses his subscription program
where he'll teach you to meet women and
make money and this sort of thing they
are packaging almost Marxist
revolutionary sounding rhetoric
with this I will give you the red pill I
I can show you the reality of reality
in this super capitalist grifter
situation now this phenomenon is not
limited to three these three guys by any
means a lot of the self-proclaimed gurus
who offer quick fixes easy solutions to
complex problems they it's the same type
of thing they are preying on people who
are sometimes desperate
often vulnerable
and they promise them whatever they need
to promise them they don't really
deliver much other than a false and
sometimes temporary sense of empowerment
and yet they continue to do really well
in our society and culture people are
drawn to them and drawn to the Allure of
the easy fix now some of them have
become more sophisticated
so they they tell you I'm not going to
give you an easy fix they've
Incorporated this is like there's an
iterative process with this stuff where
first it's overtly an easy fix and then
you have the second level charlatans who
go listen uh I'm not here to offer you
an easy fix it's it's not a One-Stop
shop but it's still this sort of very
prescribed methodology that is still the
idea of the easy fix which they tell you
will be difficult but it's still here's
the solution here's the solution and at
the end of the day what you have is
those who come to you and say
step outside of the bubble I will tell
you the real nature of reality and tell
you how to take control of it they are
actually the ones suffering from you
staying in a very bump in in a similar
bubble to the one they claim to be
getting you out of that's really the
scam and the grift and you can apply it
to all of these guys and more you know
to some degree like Deepak Deepak Chopra
although he's not as popular now it's a
slightly different version of it same
type of thing that's what's going on
with these guys I would love to prevent
people from falling for it in the first
place and if they do it would be great
to get them out but that's fundamentally
what it is that these folks are selling
and remember they are selling you
something
a Kerry lake is in shambles as her
opponent who won
has been sworn in as Governor that's
right
lawsuits and fundraising and donations
and going to Mar-A-Lago has done nothing
to prevent Katie Hobbs from becoming the
governor of Arizona the lawsuits didn't
work out the Associated Press reports
Democrat Katie Hobbs takes office as
Arizona governor and why wouldn't she
more people voted for her
and at least in theory the way our
elections work is when you get more
votes you get to win uh Katie Hobbs took
the oath of office Monday to become
Arizona's 24th governor
first Democrat to hold the office since
2009. she was sworn in during a private
ceremony at the state capitol she
formally took over from Republican Doug
Ducey Hobbes was surrounded by her
parents husband and two children she
placed a hand on a family Bible and took
the oath of office in the Govern in the
lobby of the governor's office in one of
her first official actions she signed an
executive order setting in motion a
process to update the state's policies
barring discrimination in state
employment and Contracting she's also
adding she's adding new protections
based on gender identity political
affiliation military service or veteran
status marital status culture and other
characteristics she is the fifth woman
to be governor of Arizona the last
Democratic governor of Arizona was Janet
Napolitano who resigned in 2009 to
become Barack Obama's
homeland security secretary Obama we
remember him we remember him so listen
the lawsuit didn't work out and they
shouldn't this is what happens when you
get more votes you win the election your
opponent loses your uh you get to play
the role to be the person
who carries out the duties of the office
that you ran for now we have to
understand in a sense Donald Trump has
ruined elections in that losers still
think they have a chance to win after
someone else democratically wins if they
can file the Right lawsuit convince the
right person get the right slate of
electors whatever the case may be now
Arizona didn't want Kerry Lake more
voters voted for Katie Hobbs that should
be where we move on so we have to get
really serious about the impact of
people falsely claiming that elections
they lost are rigged and actually should
be turned over to them and Kerry Lake
gave a couple of interviews here and
she's doing the entire Katie Hobbs
didn't really campaign thing it was like
Biden and blah blah blah Kerry here
former president Donald Trump said
anything about this if so what does he
say I've talked to him several times he
was was really pleased with our case he
believes we have incredible evidence he
was disappointed with the judges this
was like a couple days before Katie
Hobbs was sworn in ruling and he's happy
to see that we're going to continue to
appeal it he's feeling that America has
become very corrupt and I agree with him
we're watching he's the one who has
corrupted it to a great degree it says
Twitter um is the Twitter files kind of
un unroll or roll out I should say and
we're seeing how the FBI and other
government agencies are controlling our
speech censoring us the FBI didn't allow
me to figure out the difference between
Latino and Hispanic they're patrolling
our speech controlling a narrative to
push an agenda how the FBI was working
with social media to propel corrupt Joe
Biden's campaign and stop the America
first movement by censoring people who
are trying to get pertinent information
out that would have opened people's eyes
eyes to the corruption of the Biden
family the FBI was behind that our own
government is trying to control the
outcome of an election that is Criminal
Katie Hobbs is she nervous is she
worried
she should be I mean I know I know that
Katie Hobbs knows she didn't win this I
know that Katie Hobbs knows she cheated
the whole state knows it the whole state
knows this is a racket this is a joke
she's a joke of a candidate and I don't
know how she would even govern because
the state is not behind her and they are
losing control of their narrative as
more information gets out about how they
ran these elections how corrupt these
elections are she's a complete joke uh
you know she's couldn't even articulate
her policies she didn't show up to to
debate she didn't even campaign she's
our own we have our very own version of
Joe Biden here in Arizona and her name
is Katie Hobbs what I love about that is
these right Wingers who keep claiming oh
Biden couldn't have won he was in his
basement Katie Hobbs couldn't have won
she didn't even campaign or debate they
should really be turning their gaze
inward to realize wow we keep losing to
people who we don't believe are even
campaigning that's the humiliation
voters still prefer their opponents to
them even though they as far as their
story is concerned are campaigning while
Katie Hobbs is and Joe Biden's in his
basement so bottom line we got to get
really serious about what these false
claims of rigged elections do for us
they undermine public trust in the
electoral process they can serve to
suppress turnout which maybe is exactly
what they want to do when you claim an
election was rigged without evidence
people start to distrust the process and
it makes them less likely to vote which
maybe is exactly what they want that's
been a Hallmark of Republican politics
for a while sometimes we see these
claims incite violence and civil unrest
you look at January 6th when you make
baseless allegations that the elections
were rigged and you say Democrats took
it from you and from you and they threw
your vote in the trash some of those
people get angry and they do violent
things that's what we saw on January 6th
it can damage relationships with foreign
countries not that Republicans care but
if a candidate or a political party says
this was rigged and it wasn't and then
at some point they take power foreign
countries can look at that and say we're
not really feeling like we are actually
equals here and that you wildly claim
you lost elections that you won
elections you lost that's not a good
basis for cooperation with foreign
countries uh and lastly it just creates
Division and polarization over lies it's
unfortunate but understandable that if
one person says abortion is murder and
someone else says abortion should be
legal in most cases as most Americans do
that would be a possible source of
tension we would hopefully be able to
talk through it but that's a logical
source of tension based on real policy
differences
if you falsely claim elections were
rigged and some people believe it you're
creating that division in polarization
with baseless uh claims and we're
polarized and divided enough I don't
think that's necessary so these are all
the risks and the problems and they need
to be held accountable for doing it
early attempts to sanction Kerry Lake
have gone okay but we really have to do
something about it and and we probably
need to do something about it soon next
Wednesday January 11th will be the first
town hall of the Year 6 p.m in the East
3 P.M in the west we will be live
and taking your questions about 2023
2024 whatever everybody is welcome to
call in members will get priority and
you can sign up at joinpakman.com
that'll be streaming live remember
Wednesday January 11th we'll take a
quick break and be back after this
one of our sponsors today is ginger
armor the daily moisturizing mineral
sunscreen that's good for you and the
planet I've talked before about why I
only use mineral sunscreen instead of
chemical sunscreen I want a physical
barrier rather than chemicals absorbed
by the skin Ginger armor is an everyday
sunscreen moisturizer lip balm combo
that goes on lightweight unseen and
unscented perfect for all skin types
with powerful SPF 50 plus protection
rubs on invisibly in seconds no smell
feels good after shaving to stay
moisturized all day and the super
portable design is really good on the go
and it's made with 21 simple Earth
friendly ingredients from plants and
minerals unlike the chemical sunscreens
which can irritate skin worsen certain
conditions sting eyes Ginger armor is my
go-to for daily skin protection and
moisturizing even in Winter I know
you'll love it too it's also more
affordable than other mineral sunscreens
and it is a small business supporting
the David packman show go to
gingerarmor.com and use code Pacman for
15 off the link is below the David
packman show in this new year continues
to depend on your support we are really
an audience funded program and I would
love for you to sign up at
joinpakman.com we do the daily bonus
show for our members we offer a
commercial free audio and video stream
for our members published hours earlier
than the show is otherwise released and
when we do Town Halls like we're doing
next Wednesday January 11th our members
get a totally separate Channel and
Priority Access to talk to me all of
those things and more sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now because it really
does even though I know it's just the
start of 2023. uh this 2024 election is
rapidly wrapped rapidly getting underway
we'll talk about that a little bit later
we don't yet know exactly what will
happen today when it comes to the
swearing-in of lying Republican
Congressman elect George Santos but it
is now not only U.S criminal
investigation that Santos is under
having now found out where he is Brazil
has restarted its criminal investigation
of the very same George Santos this is
unbelievable the new or not unbelievable
as we've learned about this guy the New
York Times reports Brazilian authorities
will revive a fraud case against George
Santos a 2008 court case had been
suspended because Brazilian law
enforcement couldn't find Santos
um when he takes a seat he will do so
under the shadow of active
investigations by federal and local
prosecutors but an older criminal case
may be more pressing this stems from a
2008 incident involving a stolen
checkbook just like a pedestrian alleged
criminal is this guy and the case had
been suspended for the better part of a
decade writes the New York Times because
the police couldn't find him spokeswoman
for the Rio prosecutor's office said
that with Santos's whereabouts
identified a formal request will be made
to the doj to notify him of the charges
unnecessary step step after which the
case will proceed with or without him
the criminal case in Brazil was first
disclosed to the New York Times in a New
York Times investigation that uncovered
broad discrepancies in his resume I love
that term there were discrepancies what
is it he is accused of doing in Brazil
it's the following a month before his
20th birthday Santos entered a small
clothing store in the Brazilian city of
nidoroy outside of Rio he spent nearly
700 bucks using a stolen checkbook and a
false name court records show he
admitted the fraud to the shop owner in
2009 writing on Orcutt a popular social
media website in Brazil quote I know I
screwed up but I want to pay
in 2010 he and his mother told the
police he used the stolen checkbook of a
man his mother used to work for and made
fraudulent purchases so this this is
just a horrible horrible person and we
don't exactly know what's going to
happen today although he almost
certainly will be seated and you may
even know about that by the time Today's
Show Goes live but we now have a
situation where the Brazilian government
conveniently knows exactly where to find
him this is what Kevin McCarthy gets or
whoever right for refusing to expel this
clown and say you know what
too much dishonesty too concerning too
disturbing what he did now Republicans
are going to have to deal with or
Stonewall and pretend it's not going on
what's going on with George Santos and
it is quite a humiliating Cloud now will
they care I don't know but we're talking
about someone with outstanding warrants
in another country essentially and under
criminal investigation in the United
States if we want to be conspiratorial
and we never do except sometimes we
speculate is it possible that Santos
made a promise to McCarthy in McCarthy's
fight for the speakership which is as of
this moment that I'm recording today not
a guarantee we will know more about that
within hours is it possible Santos
promised to back McCarthy if McCarthy
promised not to try to get him kicked
out of Congress it's a question it's not
an assertion that I believe that
happened but it is certainly a sensible
question given the circumstances we
don't yet know whether Kevin McCarthy
will have all the votes he needs to be
speaker
and the question of loyalty between
these two afterwards seems very very
uncertain the other aspect to this is
there are increasingly questions about
the large amounts of money funneled
through the Santos campaign that
suggested that he maybe had a source of
funds that was unclear it didn't really
line up with his fake claims about where
he used to work I I don't know but once
we now know although this is petty in a
sense he was 19 years old in Brazil
talking about 700 he clearly is willing
to get up to some hijinks and if he was
willing to do this at age 19 what is it
he may have been willing to do over the
last year or two with regard to the
seven hundred thousand dollars that now
is a question mark in terms of the
donation he made to his own campaign a
couple people emailed me and said what
about extradition is it possible the US
would extradite him to Brazil
um I don't know I wasn't able to talk to
any lawyers about this we do have a
treaty on extradition that has been
ratified by the U.S and Brazil signed in
1961
um published in 1964 and I don't know
how plausible it really is to think
Santos might be extradited to Brazil but
this is the epitome of the Republican
party in 2023. grifter's alleged
criminals and people who are going to
spend the next two years starting today
trying to impeach Joe Biden trying to
investigate Hunter Biden it starts today
and we we'd really better be ready to
know how to deal with it it's not clear
to me that the Democratic party is
actually prepared a Ginny Thomas the
wife of Supreme Court Justice Clarence
Thomas now says that she regrets all of
those texts about the 2020 election
we're going to look at her latest claims
but I think it's important to remind you
Ginny Thomas really is like Q Anon level
out of her mind I want to remind you of
a text message that Ginny Thomas again
remember the wife of Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas who had issues
come before him related to the 2020
election Jenny Thomas texted Mark
Meadows once quote
Biden crime family and ballot fraud
co-conspirators elected officials
bureaucrats social media censorship
managers fake stream media reporters are
being arrested and detained for ballot
fraud right now and over the coming days
and will be living in barges off of
Guantanamo Bay to face military
tribunals first edition folks that's q
and on level insane and with with this
barges off of gitmo thing I always go
back to
if they're on a barge why does it have
to be off the coast of gitmo and if it's
near gitmo why does it have to be on a
barge why wouldn't they just be there of
course remember this wasn't happening
factually it wasn't happening there were
no Biden crime family co-conspirators
being arrested uh and detained they
didn't put him on a barge they didn't
put him on a cruise ship they didn't put
him on a dinghy
I mean maybe incidentally some of them
were on boats at some point in time this
quite literally didn't happen this is
just one example of how Bonkers this
woman is okay
she now says she regrets it new report
Yahoo news just a couple days before New
Year's
Jenny Thomas the conservative activist
and wife of Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas told the January 6
committee she regretted the text
messages and emails she sent in the
aftermath of the 2020 election to Mark
Meadows
Trump's former Trump's then Chief of
Staff according to a new newly released
transcript of her September interview
with the committee
uh Thomas said she regretted the fact
that the messages became public
now that's very different
I apologize because what I said was
wrong I apologize if anyone was offended
well those are two very different things
Thomas told Congressional investigators
quote I don't know how many of you would
want your texts to become public on the
front page of the Washington Post
certainly I didn't want my emotional
texts to a friend released and made
available
remember that in the messages Ginny
Thomas urged Meadows to make sure Trump
did not concede to Biden and parroted
many of the falsehoods and conspiracy
theories that were spreading among the
more Fringe claims pushed by Thomas was
the baseless theory among Q Anon that
Trump watermarked mail-in ballots to
track fraud and a claim circulated on
right-wing websites that in Thomas is
retelling as I told you the Biden crime
family is being sent to barges off the
coast of gitmo this is truly cuckoo for
Coco Puffs and my concern is people are
allowed to be crazy
that's not new people are allowed to be
unhinged conspiracy theorists we have
tens of millions of them in the United
States many of them voted for Trump in
2020. the issue is the proximity to
Clarence Thomas who was involved in
adjudicating
elements related to that election and I
guess we're meant to believe that Ginny
Thomas and Clarence Thomas never talked
about this she believed Biden crime
family conspirators were on barges but
she just never mentions it to Clarence
Thomas
that is very difficult to believe and so
of course the concern is really Clarence
Thomas and what is one of the most
radical right Supreme Courts and
arguably one of the most partisan
Supreme Courts oh I know they're
nonpartisan they simply look at the law
and they relate that to the facts and
they render a completely unbiased
political opinion legal opinion
obviously we know that doesn't that's
not the case uh that's really the
concern and that appears to be beyond
the purview of what was the January 6
committee which remember is done because
a new Congress is sworn in today
scary that she's that nuts but also
scary that she is that close to one of
the most powerful nine justices in the
United States
who heard cases related to that very
election will have more on these text
messages on our Instagram which you can
find at davidpakman show depressing
stuff I will tell you
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
I want to talk about 2024 and 2024's
possible Republican contenders I'm not
talking about Donald Trump here Donald
Trump is running at least for now unless
he drops out uh I'm talking about the
other possible contenders and Fox
Business and actually Fox News in
general has regularly been putting up
images like the one we're putting up now
this one is called possible Republican
candidates in 2024 and indeed Donald
Trump isn't on that list because Trump
is not a possible candidate he is a
candidate the folks listed include
former vice president Mike Pence current
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis Virginia
governor Glenn Younkin Larry Hogan ASA
Hutchinson Senator Tim Scott Mike Pompeo
Nikki Haley and Chris Christie and
what's really interesting about this
list is that it's a really scary list
and I thought let's just talk a little
bit about the people that are sort of
considered contenders to be Republican
uh uh uh Presidential nominee at least
hypothetically and think through how
extreme the party has gotten at the end
of the segment I'll tell you who would
be my choice if I wanted to to to limit
damage to the country and I'll tell you
in a moment
um you've got Mike Pence Mike Pence
wildly against abortion skeptical about
climate change has a history of opposing
LGBT rights wants to Build That Wall
with Mexico has been against Obamacare
never mind stronger Health Care programs
than Obamacare seems very interested in
religion more and more officially
playing a role in civil government and
also just on a personal level
is kind of a kind of a [ __ ] in the
sense that even though Trump's
supporters were calling for him to be
hanged he still doesn't totally denounce
Trump although he kind of has and he
said I think we'll have better
candidates or whatever it's just a guy
who is both spineless and has some of
the worst political views that's one
alternative to Trump for the Republican
Party okay it's pretty bad then you've
got Ron DeSantis Ron DeSantis whose
record is Florida Governor is one of
regularly signing into law bills that
restrict abortion in Florida loves
restricting abortion
um regularly weakens gun laws in Florida
at every opportunity supported repealing
the Affordable Care Act has a horrible
environmental record in Florida loves
fossil fuels opportunities to use more
fossil fuels and make it easier to use
fossil fuels DeSantis loves it and in
addition to that DeSantis
is arguably more competent than Trump
and as a result could be extraordinarily
more dangerous if he became the
president of the United States then
you've got arguably one of the slightly
less extreme people on the list Larry
Hogan but you look at his record and
it's horrifying against abortion as most
of these people are against the
Affordable Care Act tried to repeal the
Affordable Care Act supports the oil and
gas industry backwards just totally
backwards and we're supposed to see him
as less extreme to pick a senator Tim
Scott from South Carolina Tim Scott
against abortion wants to restrict
access to abortion is against any gun
safety regulation supports every tax cut
that's proposed skeptical about climate
science even though he doesn't actually
know anything about it so I could go on
and on and on it's an insane list of
people now if I look at the list and you
said to me David and this is something
that probably would bring tears to your
eyes if you came to me and said David
it's going to be one of the people on
this list tears
if you knew
it was going to be one of these people
who defeat the Democrat who would you
choose the to me it seems clear that
it's Chris Christie
and I'm glad to hear from other people
and see your opinions but when I look at
this list Pence DeSantis young and Hogan
Hutchinson Scott Pompeo Haley Christie
and then Trump who has already declared
to me it's Chris Christie Chris Christie
is
a smart guy in a way that a lot of these
other people aren't
maybe DeSantis but but you know like
Pence and uh young Christy is a smart
guy former prosecutor
more moderate socially to some degree
because of his experience as governor
and a Northeastern Governor understands
compromise and working across the aisle
in a way that some of these other people
do now I know people write to me and say
David Christie's insane what are you
talking about remember it's if one of
these people was going to be the next
president I think I'm choosing Chris
Christie and
um I'm interested to hear from others
but it's shaping up to be a pretty scary
list now fortunately or unfortunately I
don't know you know names like Don Jr or
sometimes thrown around they're not
showing up on this list at least not yet
and I think we should probably be happy
about that I now have the list of Donald
Trump's foreign bank accounts thanks to
the release of his taxes these are at
least bank accounts we know he held
during the years of the tax returns
being released Newsweek has published an
article about this and it talks about
more specifics but let's start with the
list itself and here it is in 2016 and
2017 Donald Trump had a bank account in
China we'll talk about that in 2016 and
2017 Donald Trump had a bank account in
Ireland a typical place for reducing
reducing corporate tax liability
utilized by many companies including
alphabet the parent company of Google in
2016 1718 and 2020 Donald Trump had a
bank account in the United Kingdom and
in 2016 Donald Trump had an account in
the Caribbean nation of Saint Martin a
popular but not not the most popular
place for offshoring money for the
purposes of tax avoidance now you might
say David sir he's a businessman
he has accounts what's the big deal
there's a lot of a lot of question marks
around some of these things now
generally when a president has bank
accounts in another country there are a
number of questions that we would ask
now this is for a normal person when you
have someone as corrupt and poorly
intentioned to Trump there's other
factors which we will get to but in
general president with foreign bank
accounts conflicts of interest okay U.S
president has bank accounts in other
countries there may be Financial
interests that conflict with the
interest of the United States just
obvious you know all all these
anti-semitic right-wingers want to talk
about oh conflict you you might have
dual citizen Citizenship with Israel not
me but like some American Jews maybe
have dual citizen Citizenship with
Israel but they don't want to talk about
this conflict of interest money in other
countries this could affect decision
making it could lead to actions that are
not necessarily in the best interest of
the country two we've talked about it
before with Trump vulnerability to
foreign influence U.S president has
foreign bank accounts they could be
vulnerable to influence her coercion
from other countries and it could put
the president in a position where they
might make a decision based on the
interests of foreign entities or of
Trump's interest in those other
countries then what's in the best
interests of the United States three
lack of transparency because remember
Trump worked for years to hide this
information U.S president foreign bank
accounts can be difficult for the public
and for Congress to know what are their
financial interests and that can lead to
suspicion and mistrust and subterfuge
legal issues U.S president having bank
accounts in other countries questions as
to are they complying with tax law are
they complying with disclosure
requirements Etc and then of course
there's perception however for Trump
that's not a big deal because the people
considering or in the universe of those
who would vote for him don't really seem
to care what he does now a few things to
remember about the China bank account
specifically
uh the Ivanka Trump brand you know they
got a bunch of trademarks approved very
quickly in China while Trump was
president
does that have any connection to the
China bank account we don't know again
it's speculative but these are the sorts
of questions that come up when we find
out Trump is a bank account in China
Trump's Media Group received funding
from a Chinese firm called dwac
uh that's a Chinese firm that lists
Chinese companies on American Stock
markets they are a target of SEC
investigations they have offices in
Wuhan
I'm not conspiratorial but if you want
to start asking questions about Trump
and China rather than fauci in China we
certainly have a lot of fodder for that
that is only bolstered by Trump having a
bank account there uh Trump owes money
to the Chinese government-controlled
Bank of China there's all these
different things so does this
definitively prove any crime or
wrongdoing no I guess not but it
continues to be exactly the type of
information that Trump sought to hide
worked really hard exhausted every
option to try to hide the fact that he
had tried to hide his taxes period and
and of course contained within that is
all this information that we're learning
and we don't really have answers to any
of the questions that we're asking so is
it a surprise that Trump had these
accounts it is not
could it be well you know UK bank
account he has business in the UK sure
could be but every single one of these
really should be investigated and when
you talk one I think back to Jimmy
Carter Jimmy Carter's family had that
Peanut Farm in Georgia
and he I don't remember if it was that
he uh sold his stake or exactly what
Jimmy Carter did but even to avoid the
possible appearance of some kind of bias
Jimmy Carter took steps on that think
about how many decades and Orders of
magnitude we are removed from that type
of accountability and desire to maintain
credibility it's uh it's truly
horrifying we'll continue to learn more
as a result of the tax returns that were
released of course there are only some
elements of them are are redacted as
well so there's even more to learn but
the more we do learn the worse and worse
it looks
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show Donald
Trump appears to turn on his own
anti-abortion supporters in a truth
Central post truth Central or truth
social or however you want to call it
truth essential yeah that thing the
thing that's failing uh where he is now
blaming Republicans for taking two
extreme uh position on the issue of
abortion now what's really really
interesting about this is that number
one it it's enraging many Trump
supporters number two there's a kernel
of truth to it but number three it
misses the really big picture of why a
lot of these Republicans lost which is
that they were absolutely terrible
terrible candidates so let's talk about
it Newsweek reporting Donald Trump turns
on his own supporters over abortion
Donald Trump has blamed the Republican
party's disappointing midterm
performances on the abortion issue
rather than the failure of his endorsed
candidates so the truth Central post is
as follows quote this is a beautiful new
year's message from Trump quote it
wasn't my fault that the Republicans
didn't live up to expectations in the
midterms I was 233 and 20. that's his
endorsement record it was the abortion
issue poorly handled by many Republicans
especially those that firmly insisted on
no exceptions even in the case of
capital r rape capital I incest or
capital L life of the mother that lost
large numbers of capital V voters also
the people that pushed so hard hard for
decades against abortion got their wish
from the U.S Supreme Court and just
plain disappeared not to be seen again
plus Mitch stupid dollars I think that's
something about Mitch McConnell
um uh deploying money in what Trump
considers to be a stupid way so there's
a couple interesting things here first
of all I just want to remind you when
Trump touts that endorsement record of
233 and 20 remember many of us could
have that endorsement record and what I
mean by that is Trump mostly endorsed
incumbents including some who were
running essentially unopposed in heavy
red districts he endorsed um the primary
winners in red districts it's not
difficult to rack up a lot of wins the
important thing is that the critical
races that would have made a difference
the contested races Mehmet Oz in
Pennsylvania and mastriano and Tudor
Dixon Trump failed on those and those
are actually the ones that really
mattered but more importantly Trump says
that the problem here was the abortion
issue so there's a couple things here
first of all is it true that running
against abortion with no exceptions is a
bad strategy for for Republicans yes
that is absolutely true there's limited
appeal because it's increasingly an
unpopular opinion more Americans than at
any point in the Roe v Wade era believe
that abortion should be usually legal in
most circumstances so taking a position
of no abortion no exceptions even in the
cases Trump mentions it is a bad idea
it's an inflexible position because you
can't end up compromising unless you
want to look like someone who's just
putting their finger to the wind when
you say just no abortion no exceptions
you're starting from a point of lack of
flexibility it doesn't match public
opinion sometimes focusing too much on a
single issue can hurt you because people
see you as oh that's the abortion guy or
gal you're not really going to deal with
this thing that's important to me or
that other issue or education or health
care or whatever the case may be so it
is accurate that a no exceptions
position on abortion is increasingly out
of step with public opinion and it
doesn't make sense but but but
this is also part of trump
never taking responsibility for anything
and being the victim it wasn't my fault
he starts his truth Central post by
saying they took these positions well
you endorsed them didn't you and the
reality is they picked terrible
candidates look at some of the people
they selected Kerry Lake a conspiracy
theorist who doesn't know anything about
anything and she almost won by the way
Blake Masters for Senate in Arizona
maybe one of the worst candidates in the
last 20 years Mehmet Oz a quack TV
Doctor Who it's not even clear really
lived in Pennsylvania to fight
um against John fetterman Doug mastriano
almost literally a January 6th rioter to
run against Josh Shapiro uncontroversial
good candidate
the right opinions on so many so many
issues Tudor Dixon Herschel Walker who
can barely even speak so was it the
abortion issue or was it really an issue
of poor candidates and I think we know
the truth
abortion is important
but the decision by the Supreme Court
was a little too early to affect the
2022 races as much as maybe some of us
on the left hoped and some of the
Republicans with that no exceptions view
on abortion did win
it was the terrible candidates that lost
now in terms of the impact uh on Trump's
supporters of trump saying this the
super pro-lifers are not happy and it's
sort of beyond the scope of this segment
to talk in more detail about that but
they there are some extreme the people
for whom abortion is the most important
issue
and they hate it and want no exceptions
are very very unhappy with what Donald
Trump is saying we'll see if it affects
his 2024 candidacy which is not exactly
off to a brilliant start let's now take
a quick look at this humiliating event
that Donald Trump did on New Year's Eve
Donald Trump had a New Year's Eve party
at Mar-A-Lago on New Year's Eve he
announced that he would be available to
the media barely any media showed up and
Trump dodged questions and generally
seemed extremely confused we're going to
look at a couple of Clips just to ring
in the New Year together
uh Trump was asked a question about a
National Abortion ban he ignores it
calls on a different reporter Trump
looks disoriented Melania looks
miserable it's all just crazy
Mr President
so he's asked would you support a
National Abortion ban he doesn't like
the question he just calls on someone
else let's let's watch it again
Mr President the doj FBI have weaponized
against you will you commit to going
after them in your second term this is a
question he likes I think it's a
disgrace
Justice it's never been anything like
this and it is description and thank you
for that question
that question he appreciates
um at another moment
um he's asked about Ron DeSantis and
then he talks about the border of
Ukraine and Russia it doesn't make any
sense what he's saying it's just totally
confused garbled speech I do apologize
also because the audio isn't great on
this segment but I think we'll be able
to hear it
awesome
[Music]
he's just ignore the few questions he's
getting half of him he doesn't like
Ukraine and Russia
and um
country
Mr President so this is a section from
before
the weaponization Justice there's never
been anything like this out of this
disgraceful and thank you for that
question
all right anyway as you can see almost
no media showed up you see a microphone
from oan there and just really really
failing and then inside the party Donald
Trump offered the following
inspirational and uplifting message
going into the new year
energy who are watching nuclear weapons
talked about all the time or watching
inflation going through the roof
all of these things that we're watching
and it's so unnecessary and so sad to
see now we have airports where people
can't fly the only good thing is
connected from this standpoint we needed
some seats so we lost about 50 we sold
about 200 extra so but it's it's sad
when people can't come from New York to
Florida the airports are like we're like
a third world country there you go an
inspirational message of peace and love
we are like a third world country and
people can't fly anymore so listen it's
going we're sort of poking fun at this
because it's ridiculous and hilarious
and pathetic but um I have no idea what
to expect for 2023. if you came to me
and you said sir by the end of 2023
Will trump even still be a candidate for
the Republican nomination I don't know
where I would bet on an even money bet I
don't know if I take the bet that Trump
will still be a candidate by the end of
this year uh or that he will not very
difficult to say things are odd things
are strange and we're just getting
started I want to play a voicemail for
you today remember we have a voicemail
number 2192 David P that will show you
how quickly bad information spreads
yesterday during an NFL football game an
NFL player named Demar Hamlin
collapsed after taking a hit he was on
defense seemed to take a hit sort of to
the left chest and stood up and then
collapsed the game was called off the
latest news that I have as of this
particular moment and I should make sure
that it's accurate as of right now he is
in critical condition
um and we we don't know exactly what his
uh prognosis is DeMar Hamlin uh we're
hoping for the best
immediately there's speculation on
Twitter that he collapsed and died
because of the covet vaccine and I
didn't think this would reach our
audience But Eric from Mass right away
called in about it take a listen to this
hey David you believe yet it's Eric from
Mass
um guy just died on the field from the
vaccine now he didn't die he's alive and
we're hoping he will survive he did not
die but it was not from the vaccine
rest in peace
guy just died on the field for the
vaccine in an NFL again
uh never happened before
has never happened
um you look like a ghost since you've
been sick yeah actually what's funny is
we had an issue with our white balance
last week I did look like a ghost but it
had nothing to do with covet we fixed
the issue um I've never seen something
so white my life
um and you did this you you told people
to get it
and you'll be held accountable for that
I mean I don't know if it'll be through
the law but morally and you're gonna
have to live with the fact that you told
people to get poisoned I mean but you
probably don't matter to you so whatever
but I'm just figured I'd let you know to
my hand went dead at 24 Monday Night
Football collapse and died on the fields
in a vaccine rest in peace yeah so again
he's he's alive
um you know the the sad thing about this
is
uh we have so much information so so
first of all
we don't know Demar Hamlin's vaccination
status first of all so even the
assumption that he's vaccinated is one
that is not based in fact but of course
this is the new thing
conspiracies tend to shift over time and
the new thing now is this the the phrase
they're using is suddenly died and the
story that's being told is young people
suddenly dying from the covet vaccine
even though there is not actually
evidence of that and um for a lot of
people they don't care that there's no
evidence of it and I think Eric from
Mass falls under that um category now
there's going to be a lot of time to
figure out exactly what happened with
Demar Hamlin but the best explanations
that are speculative of course that I've
seen so far are that when you get hit I
forget the name of the condition but
when you get hit hard in the left chest
blunt force to the left chest
if that hit happens
coinciding with the particular moment in
the heart rhythm it can cause exactly
this and it can be very serious we don't
yet know the number one concern right
now is DeMar Hamlin's health but um when
we have better explanations
when people go to vaccine vaccine
vaccine even in the absence of evidence
that Hamlin was vaccinated I hope that
nobody in my audience
is going to fall for that type of thing
and we saw some of it on Twitter
so I saw some tweets sent to me and
here's a voicemail from Eric from from
Mass
um this is what happened is really scary
but the speed with which baseless
disinformation spreads is also really
really scary when all you have is a
hammer in this case the hammer is
vaccines are bad everything looks like a
nail my my camera white balance problem
last week was because I got a covet
vaccine rather than my camera was doing
something weird
uh football player collapses that was
the vaccine do we even know he was
vaccinated well we don't but it must
have been the vaccine
don't fall for this stuff
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we're going to talk about the
fight for the speakership among
Republicans and uh votes coming soon we
will know who the speaker will be very
soon we are going to try to figure out
what is happening in China with kovid
there are reports of bodies piling up
crematoria overwhelmed it's crazy what's
going on and we're going to talk about
States raising their minimum wages in
2023 where can workers expect higher pay
where are the wages going even higher in
2024 we have the list we will talk about
it we will tell you all of those stories
and more when I am joined by producer
Pat from Florida
on the bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money sir
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves as bad sir yes sir all of
that and more on the bonus show sign up
at joinpakman.com and remember that next
Wednesday January 11th at 6 Eastern we
are doing the next David packman show
Town Hall it will be streaming live so
anyone who wants to watch it can watch
it
anyone who wants to participate can
participate via Discord and our members
get Priority Access via Discord so sign
up at joinpakman.com coupon code 24
starts now it's 2023 and it is great to
be back
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors Ginger armor is
the daily moisturizing mineral sunscreen
perfect for any skin type chemical
sunscreens can cause health issues
including skin irritation and stinging
eyes but with ginger armors ingredients
from plants and minerals and it being
scent free and rubbing on invisibly in
seconds it's the best get 15 off with
code Pacman using the link below